well the world is laughing at his Pat
yesterday on just his fifth day in
office President Trump largely cancelled
out the efforts of President Obama and
many environmentalists when he signed
executive orders to revive construction
of the Keystone XL and Dakota access
pipelines also executive orders to
minimize environmental regulation of
other infrastructure projects totally
and utterly plutocratic oleg our kacal
retrograde nonsense and the debate
around whether or not to build Keystone
XL has been going on for years President
Obama rejected it in 2012 because of
completely valid concerns about
emissions and spills and disturbances of
landed water resources
here's Trump making a big deal out of
signing this like he's some kind of hero
for doing this with regard to the
construction of the Keystone pipeline
something that's been in dispute and
it's subject to a renegotiation of terms
by us we're going to renegotiate some of
the terms and if they'd like we'll see
if we can get that pipeline built a lot
of jobs 28,000 jobs great construction
job yeah by the way how weird are these
little videos when Trump invites in the
media to narrate himself signing stuff I
mean truly just the ego is on display
there by the way he talks about jobs
construction of the pipeline would
create some temporary construction jobs
but even the State Department says it
would have no significant impact on
long-term employment solar power plants
for example they can employ people too
and we all remember the recent protests
by the Standing Rock Indian Reservation
and others in solidarity with them
against the building of the Dakota
access pipeline it violates treaties
with the federal government it poses
huge threats to the environment in
archeology and then here is Trump
signing another executive order to try
to move forward with the Dakota access
pipeline this is with respect to the
construction of the Dakota access
pipeline dakota access yes
again subject to terms and conditions to
be negotiated by us both projects were
halted both may be on their way to
completion now of course Obama rejected
the Keystone pipeline because it carried
tar sands crude oil which releases a
particularly large amount of climate
change in greenhouse gases we already
know Trump thinks climate change is a
hoax and within hours of the
inauguration the Trump administration
announced its plan to eliminate the u.s.
climate action plan I referenced this a
couple times he has this thing called
the America first energy plan the world
is laughing at us Europe countries like
China and India they're leading the
world a new energy renewable energy
we've got Rick Perry set to lead the
Department of Energy we've got the
former CEO of Exxon set to be our
Secretary of State while Trump turns
back the clock with American energy and
wants a fast lane to destructive energy
that won't even really create jobs and
perhaps not surprisingly there's a
conflict of interest angle here too
because Donald Trump has a 1 million
dollar stake in energy transfer Partners
which you have Dakota axises parent
company he claims to have gotten rid of
those stocks but we don't know for sure
and yet no I guess though their CEO
donated 165 thousand dollars to his
campaign oh yeah there's a big quid pro
quo going on there China makes a pact to
fight climate change with European
nations at the World Economic Forum last
week Chinese President Xi Jinping says
that the Paris agreement is a milestone
and that we must make sure it doesn't
get derailed India building the world's
first large-scale unsubsidized co2
conversion unit which save 60,000 tons
of co2 per year they've built the
largest solar energy plant we've got the
EU bank investing billions a year to
fight climate change and the Trump
administration wants to revive coal and
build pipelines we want to beat China
according to Trump we want to win again
but Trump is pushing fossil fuel
pipelines doesn't anybody realize that
we are the past and China and India are
the future on this we are falling behind
funny also that despite being again
President Obama's use of executive
actions Donald Trump is going completely
nuts with executive actions I'm sure
that's different though take a break
back after this